this group of asylum seekers is trying
to climb the fence that bites Mexico and
the United States among them is a four
year old girl
accompanied by her mother not only is it
a must with the wine
this is it I know why they call
everything you tell that Berlin was
about the approach that don't pay the
same
I know bed and I did blow out the fire
you go
[Applause]
[Music]
other and her four-year-old daughter
monster rats spent seven weeks traveling
2,000 miles from under us to DeWanna
mainly on foot
their aim is to claim asylum in the
United States
positional Amira siempre y hasta Yong a
tratar de cruzar commercially admitted
where jessica Sokka Sokka smithy fishing
Jackie anonymity hunky Australian Iolani
comida Nina and per se llaman la espera
Co no tenemos trabajo and to say just a
simple comedy physics already we're the
wunens government is restricting
humanitarian aid in an attempt to shut
down camps like this migrants like other
and her daughter don't have access to
bathrooms or running water and many have
fallen sick
Akeno surveyor our Aquino survey say
sent art a decir no puedo no lo he say
no Cervino para que ahora hasta 1410
Tasya haces aquí ahora Ponte como dicen
la Pantera Nebbia puesto yes
the US Department of Homeland Security
also adds to their despair by limiting
the number of people who can seek asylum
to a few dozen per day because of this
restriction thousands have to wait for
months before they can reach you a soil
demacia
yellowcake amo pasando same memo cetera
see suppose really others decision to
cross illegally and turn herself into
Border Patrol may seem like a way to
jump the queue but climbing the fence in
Tijuana is a dangerous choice many
migrants are robbed kidnapped hurt or
even killed in the attempt an other will
also risk being separated from her
daughter for makaras opossum yellow pass
a motion casa de todo porque estas el
momento and a no sabes ET val Ramirez
yaa pasar algo
the journey from on duelist the u.s. can
be dangerous for anyone but especially
for women and children other found safe
even numbers by traveling with the
caravan then contrast say some dr. phero
excellent a persona is a letter some new
economy and a house a unique we have a
meeow meeow
[Music]
okay pero time and they came I
cameo by the amigas you selected I show
your American bomber then try Hank
involve play attacking otros
Hey Mutombo starred on DoCoMo car nearly
every ant there may be playing oh hi
[Music]
Alice
phenelzine after praying inside the tent
the group heads to the border odda
embarked on this journey because she and
her daughter were being harassed by
gangs she is risking everything to save
her daughter's life
just a little motor oil Laura the
persecution the pania
you know they okay and Stan amirali nice
episode cause Armacost sentiment
Amanda's army universe say you want me
how come the alien don't say Joe the
city same another interesting manager
Sally the Dora por que que poner una a
new shopper a while ago do not know
service or similarly or like to come
into a salad their first attempt at
jumping the fence is disrupted by
journalists first Alessandro beloved
return period Easter but this group is
nowhere close to giving up
[Applause]
[Music]
kneel on the heel
[Applause]
telephone numbers a little solo cat with
[Music]
[Applause]
a little peepee
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for watching part 2 for series
on the humanitarian crisis of the
quanity
coming up next is a story about an
accompany mine are seeking asylum in the
US please support us and subscribe to
our Channel